let's go to Grant from Iowa City Iowa
Grant welcome to the program what's on
your mind today
uh hey David
um I saw your interview with uh Ben
Dixon yesterday it was really
interesting thank you um yes clear that
uh the Christian Nationals movement is
definitely growing or at least becoming
more bold yes
um and so I was just wondering I know I
don't know if you identify as like
agnostic or atheist I'm not sure but so
I don't know how much um
interaction like personally you've had
with um Evangelical conservative
Christians do you think
um not the politicians like just like
General people in public
um do you think they're motivated more
by
um a desire for power or are they
motivated more by fear
um personally in my experience I kind of
grew up in that kind of you know realm
and uh I think there's a there's a great
fear they have uh I was like afraid of
like God punishing them
my most extensive interactions with
American evangelicals was when I went to
Indiana because my girlfriend has family
there and the my my girlfriend's Jewish
but is she has a part of her family
that's Evangelical Christians and what I
saw in speaking to them a lot of fear
and a lot of fear-driven conspiratorial
beliefs
and it did not feel to me like now I'm
not talking about politicians I'm
talking about random people which was
your question it did not feel like a
thirst for power was there Guiding Light
it genuinely seemed like it was fear
yeah yeah that's just interesting to me
because I think um
just on my own experience like when I
went to college and stuff and just had
you know classes where we were looking
at other uh just groups in the world I
was like oh
um this is not that scary and uh right
there's nothing to be afraid of and and
like
I don't know even just like I'm still a
Christian but like
um my view of like God has changed so
much from what it used to be just like
this this angry God he wanted to punish
us anytime he could
um so I don't know I kind of think I've
enjoyed talking with more conservative
Christians and evangelicals um over the
last few years because I kind of like
uh just get to know how they're feeling
about stuff and offer different
perspectives and for some of them it
seems like oh okay
um they start to learn
like it's it's not as you know
horrifying as as it might be I guess to
um yeah that's really interesting to
hear and that you came to that
conclusion because one of the things
that I've thought about is you know I
guess I guess I consider myself agnostic
although whenever I explain My Views
people will write in and they'll say
David you're actually an atheist
whatever call me whatever you want but
my view is uh I think it's completely
possible that some kind of God or higher
power exists I've just not seen any
evidence of it but one of the things
that I've come to believe is contrary to
much of this fire and brimstone stuff
from the Evangelical side if there were
such a higher power it seems to me that
if God created such complicated uh human
beings God would not be this black white
vindictive
um uh Arbiter that some Christianity
makes him out to be and uh it sounds
sort of like you've come to the same
idea
oh yeah absolutely absolutely so
um well I can let you get some other
people now all right but I just thank
you so much I appreciate the call yeah
thanks for taking my call and in fact
what Grant from Iowa is letting me do is
just end the segment because we are at
the end of our time today I always am
just so broken up that I cannot get to
everyone who's waiting to talk to me
but that means that hopefully next week
some people will call in so I will speak
to you then we'll take a quick break and
be back with more right after this